[Musique]
cent treize ans déjà que le marché fréry
trône au procureur de belfort 60 mètres
de long dix sept mètres de haut
une véritable cathédrale de briques de
verre et d'acier
construite en 1905 dans le style
caractéristique de gustave eiffel
un lieu que l'historien andré large et
connaît bien il en a étudié l'évolution
au fil des ans
l'époque de l'acier triomphant on avait
eu le viaduc de garabit tong avait eu la
tour eiffel on avait eu les battait
pavillon baltard à l'époque et pour
faire ce bâtiment est bien la ville a
fait appel à une entreprise parisienne
qui en avaient l'expérience c'était
l'entreprise schwartz et morère qui
avait construit les grilles du grand
palais ainsi que les serres municipales
de paris un lieu qui a traversé le temps
sans trop d'encombrés mais qui avait
besoin d'être remis au goût du jour
électricité aménagements intérieurs il y
a quelques années la mairie a souhaité
lui redonner un petit coup de jeune
on a commencé par enlever l'estrade ce
qui nous a permis de rajouter des
commerces
aujourd'hui nous avons 43 stands qui
fonctionne le samedi matin il fallait
aussi ordonné un petit peu un petit peu
de vie de convivialité nous avons créé
les aires de jeux pour les enfants s'est
plaint le samedi matin une aire de
convivialité où on peut effectivement se
restaurer prendre un café manger des
assiettes avec des produits
essentiellement du marché
aujourd'hui le marché fréry est un lieu
incontournable du commerce de
centre-ville
car ici on trouve de tout du fromage aux
produits bio médine franche comté
[Musique]
sarafina gens très bien on va le
syndicat à l'architecturé vraiment très
bien on a de la chance de boer
travailler dans un lieu comme ceux ci on
a de la chance voilà qui est beaucoup
monté viennent
c'est beau c'est super ces trois mois ou
36 mois ouvert les vendredis et samedis
matin le lieu à même ses aficionados
surtout pour les produits venus
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans
ce marché fréry vous venez souvent les
marchands et la marchandise je viens
tous les vendredis depuis trois ans
voilà je suis fidèle au marché way et je
suis très très content de ce marché
aussi bien la qualité des produits que
les
commerçants sont très gentils
voilà tout est dit les jeunes cherchent
seulement l'italie en france alors qu'on
y vient de laisser tomber comme ça c'est
pas parce que je travaille et que je
parle bien je sais que mon cd produit
qui vient d'arrêter les sélectionnés de
celui s'opère et voilà les gens d'y voir
la qualité et ce sont l'italie quoi plus
d'un siècle après sa naissance le marché
fréry n'a pas fini sa mue un vaste
chantier de restauration de sa façade
extérieure est prévu les travaux doivent
commencer 2020
[Musique]